I got so much like life experience from
this because I had to get a hundred
dudes in college to do stuff they didn't
want to do with no hard Authority and
they're also like friends of mine so
it's like how do I get them to do
community service cuz we have to do a
certain amount of hours they have to
show up at the events our house is
notorious for showing up really late and
partying really late and I was trying to
explain to them I was like guys if we
all show up earlier to the parties our
parties aren't going to be like twice as
big they'll be like five times as big
girls are walking on the Frat row or
whatever and they see all these parties
where the line is is where it's probably
happening if it's there's no line
there's no real party and so we're all
getting there really late but the guys
who got a little bit earlier get the
Snowball Effect so then a line starts
earlier then more people go to the
fraternity and then it just starts
compounding